hello
I'm a developmental psychologist
and I study how infants learn about
their worlds
and they learn about their worlds quite
rapidly they start out with minimal
skills
but by the time they reach one two three
years old
they show
prowess and generative intelligence they
are inventive and they learn very
rapidly from Individual experiences
now critically much of the knowledge
that's out there in the world to be
learned as latent and it's unrealized
without some direct physical action on
the World by either the infant or by the
infant's social partnership
this I think is uh profoundly important
to understanding how human learners
are so good
at learning and generalizing information
at each moment in time there is a strong
link
between the internal system the mind
that does the learning and experience at
each moment in time the brain both by
generating behavior and controlling the
sensory inputs received determines what
is learned
and it is the activations within the
brain tied to the brain's own internal
Dynamics and to the generated
the generation of behavior and to the
sensory inputs that change the brain and
that constitute learning each moment
of experience is thus dependent on this
complex dynamic system of internal
Machinery sensory input
and knowledge comes to be instantiated
in the system
this means
that the learning mechanisms and the
data for learning are not independent
the internal mental processes that
generate behavior and do the learning
okay are the same and they have been
linked over evolutionary time
developmental time and real time and
their connection to the data for
learning what this has suggested to me
is that if we're going to make progress
on understanding how it is that human
learning is nuanced Innovative and Rapid
then what we really need to do is not
just think about the internal mechanisms
we need to think about the link between
those internal mechanisms and the
structure of experience itself because
those internal mechanisms play a direct
role in structuring experience so what I
try to do to try to understand how it is
that young infants learn all they do in
the short time that they do
is trying I'm trying to do a Precision
study of the structure of everyday
experience
and so what I've been doing for actually
a number of years now since 2008 is
putting wearable sensors on infants and
toddlers as they go about their business
we do it in uh four different ways one
what we call the multi-sensory data set
here it's high resolution the infants
are all strapped up with wearable
sensors of various kinds motion sensors
had mounted eye trackers and so forth we
put them in naturalistic context but
it's maybe not quite totally natural but
we get great data
we have the toy room studies which stand
sort of in between that where infants
wear head mounted eye trackers or head
cameras and audio recorders and then
they play or interact in a free-flowing
way
um in in the laboratory
and then we have
um the home view sets data sets one done
in the US which we call home View and
one done in India which we call India
view in which uh infants and toddlers
wear head cameras and we record everyday
experience trying to get about eight
hours in a single day or across multiple
days from an individual infant
and what uh the doing of this work has
taught me is that there are multiple
time scales that we might want to think
about in terms of how we think about the
structure of the data of experience
first there is developmental time
so the structure of experience is
radically different for very young
children who can't do anything they can
just sort of sit and look around and
listen
to more active infants who begin to
reach and hold objects to toddlers who
are walking around making things happen
using objects instrumentally so there
are big changes in the nature of
experience across developmental time
itself
there's also the time scale of when you
are let's say three months old the
multiple meal times or day in and day
out experiences of faces that you see so
there is these kind of periods of
development which we can organize by the
motor skill of the infants
um and they have day in and day out
experiences in their house repeated
experience of similar sorts of events
and then there are the individual
episodes of experience itself
face-to-face play with Mom one day
watching your brother play with toys
another day or
meal time in a sing or play time some
single context-bound episode of
experience the time scale of these
episodes of experience are minutes
over the course of my
work looking at the structured
experience I have come to be compelled
by the idea that it is a statistical
structure of single episodes
their temporal and statistical structure
that underlies the prowess of humans
ability to learn from very few
experiences and to make far and
Innovative generalizations from those
experiences and that's what I'm going to
concentrate on today
so here's the structure of the talk I'm
going to tell you about one finding that
took me to looking closely at episodes
of experience
as the PowerHouse behind human learning
and then I'm going to talk about the
statistics of individual episodes of
experience and third about how those
properties of individual episodes of
experience may be the secret ingredient
between
rapid learning by humans and far and
Innovative generalization
so to the fat first finding that really
convinced me I I've got to take
what happens in individual episodes of
learning seriously there are multiple
findings that have told me this I'm just
going to tell you about one
um
and what that what these findings
concern is how it is that infants learn
their first object names we know from
laboratory evidence that infants know
their first objects names by their first
birthday they don't talk they don't say
those names but they already receptively
albeit fragile know a number of object
names we know this because when we put
these babies in experiments and we put
two figures up on the screen let's say a
banana and somebody's arm pictures of
these and we say banana babies reliably
look at the named object okay now they
only do it for very few objects those
that are very common in the early
experiences of infants but what these
data tell us is that at minimum these
babies have formed an association
between visual features of category
instances and the name of the object in
their language
we have
no idea the field none zero of how it is
that they do this okay
there are no good explanations at all
you can't teach babies this young object
names and laboratory experience
experiments
um we have no idea
so
the founding assumption for all accounts
and experimental studies of the learning
Early Learning of object names is that
infants learn these first names to
extensive definition by linking
co-occurring herd names and seeing
things that seems right
but
the natural statistic of words and
reference suggests that this founding
assumption is it not wrong that's
probably too strong a statement at least
deeply incomplete
so the date I'm going to tell you about
next comes from home View
where we kids were we're in infants and
toddlers wear head cameras in the home
for multiple days
uh giving us about eight hours of uh
head camera video
um so they have warehead cameras we have
audio recordings on the infants uh it's
in the home there are no experiments
present and the day that I'm going to
tell you about today comes from 87 meal
times for infants between 6 to 11 months
of age that's a period when they should
be receptively learning some object
names by the laboratory studies now meal
times are defined very broadly
is defined as food being eaten so
sometimes the child is sitting in a high
chair at the table but other times we're
talking about Cheerios on the living
room floor okay anything with food or
dishes or anybody eating the parent the
child the dog counts as Meal Time
for infants this age these kinds of
events occur about five times a day
so what we did is in this study is we
looked at 40 categories all of which
have normatively early learned names
which children might show some receptive
knowledge up by the time they're 12
months of Age and what we measured were
the visual instances of the objects and
Views and the in view from the head
camera and the spoken names that they
heard
okay here's what the data looked like
um and these are in some ways remarkable
in some ways or not okay so if you look
we're going to count to your proportions
of meal times meal times so these are
frames and View for the objects in view
but the proportion of individual meal
time frames and the
objects that were common in these um
Home Videos
were present many of them a lot of the
time but sometimes not so much okay but
nonetheless the visual objects for these
40 early learned object names were
present in many meal times each of them
but when you look across all these meal
times the 87 meal times and you asked if
the infant ever hear those object names
the answer is this is the middle Slide
the answer is no they did not okay
parents rarely rarely named any of these
objects now it is not that these parents
were weird this is exactly if you listen
to these uh watch these head cameras and
listen to the conversations it sounds
just like parents talk to a 6 to 12
month old infants they're saying lovely
things like hi sweetie how are you oh
come on eat this appointment would you
do that sweetie but they're not going
around naming objects the names are
rarely hurt
however
when you go in this is the third panel
to individual Meal Time episodes
what you see
is it the child might be able to learn
the word spoon
if they could do it in one meal time so
for example there is an example of
spoons being present and one meal time
in which is named ten times another meal
time which is named seven times could
the child possibly the infant be
learning these object names from very
sparse
Meal Time experiences in which they are
named
it's not clear
how that could be done but really seven
seven times a spoon be named in one meal
time be enough
all right
here's what it looks like if you try to
think of simulating over 200
simulated meal times as to what it would
look like what you would see is that
most of the meal times the visual
objects would be present
but
those are the blue ones
the names are never present without the
object so there's no yellow bars
but there would be
a few
experiences like the one for spoon here
in which you would get a spoon named
when it was visually present at a meal
time
so these are the kinds of results that
said what I need to know better than we
do is what happens in these individual
experiences
what could possibly be going on there
that could lead to one episode or two or
three episodes
of hearing an object name
and learning its reference
so to basically just summer up summarize
the results thus far for visual
reference they're pervasive day in and
day out
children could easily learn not easily
children could potentially learn the
object categories through some form of
incremental unsupervised learning with
no labeling that's absolutely possible
okay but the question is how does the
name get learned they've got to somehow
link the name to the object is that
learned within single episodes
so after these results what we have
started doing some number of years ago
is trying to really understand what
happens within single real world
experiential episodes
and that's what I'm going to go to now
the statistics of episodes of experience
and here I'm going to move first to um a
study in the toy room this is one in
which we had one-year-old Toddlers and
their parents come into play We dumped
33 toys a haphazard collection on the
floor the instructions to the parents
were to let their children play with the
toys and if they should interact with
them as they normally would I'm going to
give you the results
um from two studies
um
they're pretty similar and I'm just
going to intermix the results as I need
them to make my point
so the question we asked is what are the
statistical patterns Within These single
continuous episodes of experience
what we do is we code we code it
uh handling by the infant handling by
the parent and referential talk by the
parent
infants don't talk these infants were
not talking very much and we excluded
there
noises which are hard to code I should
note that different dyads because they
have 33 objects on the floor and half
Hazard Arrangements played with
um different toys okay and it's a 10
minute episode all right
and so what do we observe from these
studies okay
we observed that these 10 minute play
episodes are characterized by a suite of
Statistics that are absolutely well
known for natural phenomena and for
human generated behaviors
first of all we represented the data as
a Time series of discrete behaviors
directed to different toys
and those different behaviors have time
Siri exhibited periods of repetition
continuity of the same toy in time and
also periods where they seem to flit
among different types of toys
the interactions
engagements with the same toy showed a
bursty structure characterized by short
legs and long legs the frequency
distribution with zipian in which a very
few objects were frequently engaged by
the child and the parent and
when one put those transitions of
engagements into
um Network form
it comprised a well-structured small
world Network let me just show you all
of this I'll begin with the frequency
distributions
so shown over here on B is a frequency
distribution
for rank order different children are
paying playing with different toys so
rank order number one toy for toddler
one is different than it is for toddler
two Sally may have played with the phone
a lot a whole lot and Johnny may have
engaged most with the duck okay but by
rank order what you see is what all the
infants show is
um high frequency play with very few
objects and then a long tail in which
objects are engaged quite rarely
parents distributions show the same
properties and parent talk about the
object shows the same properties and
there is absolute concordance in the
objects that toddlers frequently handle
that parents frequently handle and that
parents talk about that is the most the
correlation between the frequency
of toddler handling parent handling
toddler handling parent talk parent
handling and parent talk all are within
individual dyads reliable and with r is
greater than .60
they are playing with the same objects
favoring the same objects so in most in
what you do here in in panel C you what
we have here is the mean proportion of x
toddler handling parent handling or
parent talk to individual toys as a
function of rank order
shows the overall frequency distribution
that this is the mean for the individual
children the uh bars of the standard
deviations and then some what I'm going
to tell you next we divide the objects
into what we call topic and common
objects based on their information
theoretic value Within the play session
that is the high frequency topics are we
call topics because they're old
information during playing since I play
with them a lot constitute the main
themes let's say and the comments
constitute newer information it's just a
way to look at the frequency high
frequency and low frequency in a
reasonable way in the data
all right so the next thing I want to
tell you is that these were bursting and
so we coded the transitions these are
sampling at one Hertz and the ones that
are most interesting are when they move
to a new object you know so this play
with the duck in one and then it moves
to play with the giraffe
and also when they are transitions to
the same object that is if you're
playing with the hammer in a cow in one
you're playing with the cow in the next
We compare the uh frequencies of these
different kinds of transitions with ten
thousand with permutations random
permutations of individual diads um time
series with ten thousand permutations
for each die at this search as our
Baseline for asking whether the
structure and um
The observed timelines for the dyads
um go beyond the frequency distribution
alone and what I want to show you is
that
and what I want to show you is that
there are
um the two kinds of transitions
characterize the
uh observed play
about 31 of all transitions at one
second are to a new object to transition
from the giraffe to the cow let's say
and about 30 percent are to the same
object these would be South Loops in a
network
Hammer you're playing with hammer you're
playing with one second later and notice
that the
randomly observed networks the randomly
permuted networks which maintain the
frequency distribution have very few
South loops okay
that have a lot more
no transitions to No Object at all and
so forth the average self-loop length
continuity is sticking with the same
object in time has a run length and this
is at one Hertz a
4.12 so about four seconds okay
the topic objects that children play
with are returned to throughout the
whole play session okay but interleaved
with exploration of new objects so it's
not the case that they play a whole lot
with one high frequency object for the
first period of time then play with a
different high frequency object then
play with a different high frequency
option rather the objects that they play
with
frequently what we've called the topic
objects are like the topics in discourse
return to throughout the whole session
so what's shown here in B is the mean
proportion of dyad Acts that were
directed to the topic or the common
object for each quarter that is 2.5
minutes at the 10 minute play session
and we show it for the individual top
five objects in uh figure C
and as you can see the top five objects
are each engaged and throughout the
session so what the children are doing
is they're playing primarily with just a
few of the objects but they interleave
this play
with objects that are rarely played with
the whole these all these properties
repetition exploration burstiness to
frequency distribution
they jointly create a well-structured
network
shown on the left are the networks for
three individual diads of the 32
contributing children and that the
individually random from the networks
from the 10 000 random permutations of
that diet
let's play
the edges shown in the we're not showing
self Loops here for the simpleization of
visualization all the edges are
non-directional and Edge strength is
indicated by proximity
the statistics
of these individual networks computed
for individual die ads
shows a lot of structure
a lot of relate repeated relational
patterns and higher order relational
patterns among the toys that were
engaged
and for each of these we can compare
them to the random Network so in the
figures on the right I am showing
Network measures for each rank
up object the most played with object
the second most played with object and
so forth for The observed and random
Network these are means across each of
the individual children contributing
data and first of all you can see that
the strength
of individual self-loops the strengths
of self-loops
is much much higher in the observed than
in the random Networks
you can see the strength of d edges
those are what are shown in the figure
the ones that go to new objects
are weaker
for The observed Network than for the
random Network this makes sense what
does structure in a network means it
means that there are selective
connections the random network is just
driven by
the frequencies of the individual
objects engaged with and the more
frequent objects connect to lots of
different things
degrees is a measure of how many
different nodes or objects each object
connects to and again this is stronger
in the random networks than it is in the
observed networks again this is an
indicator of the greater structure in
the observed networks it is not the case
that
it's that transitions between all the
objects are likely some transitions
never occur instead some are repeated
the last two measures between this and
cluster coefficient show the higher
order relations observed in the network
betweenness means that if you play with
the dog and you play with the cow
but you never connect those to each
other every time they're connected
that you play Go Dog vote cow then boat
okay stands between the dog and the cow
in the network and play some role in
linking those elements together and as
you can see the observed networks of
nodes have greater betweenness
um and these are so particularly so for
the topic Notes The High Frequency nodes
they are connected systematically
um or serve as uh organizing point
systematically between all the toys
the cluster coefficient measures the
transitivity of these connections so if
you play with the cow and then play with
a hammer and then you play with the
hammer and play with a giraffe do you
also play with the cow and the giraffe
that would mean that relations and
transitions were transitive and you as
you can see there is much more higher
order structure in the observed than the
um random Network
this structure that we've observed here
is a structure that's also observed in
discourse
in narrative in conversation in stories
this is the structure of topics that get
repeated and Link everything together
that integrate old and new information
and that hold the whole thing together
with a few
predictive repeated relations among the
elements
all right so now
what I want to do is is talk about how
these statistics
statistics that are
common to human well-known to be common
to human generated behavior and to
Natural experiences more generally maybe
the secret ingredient behind the rapid
learning and far generalization that
characterized in human learning by
humans including learning by very young
humans so I'm going to do this in two
parts first how these statistics May
support rapid learning of whole episodes
of experience and second how these
memories these learned memories of whole
episodes of experience May support
Innovative generalization
so first of all
in work that we are doing now we have
shown that uh these statistics are in
and of themselves sufficient to lead to
Rapid formation of durable and
expressible cortical memories of single
episodes of experience
and our demonstration of this emerges
from our recent advances in the study of
how durable and expressible cortical
memories are formed in both animal
studies and in human studies and what
that research suggests is that
whole episode memories
can rapidly form from a single
experience
when the experience is multimodal
when the context is social
when it involves action so that what one
does at one moment has a consequence and
constrains what can happen in future
moment and when there are predictive
relations across multiple time scales
that is not just when you pick up the
toy that
pick up toy one that predicts that
you're going to pick up toy two next but
rather than picking up toy one early in
the event also predicts what might
happen later in the event
all these properties
are understood
is leading to
persistent recurrent activation across
multiple neural networks
and the idea the theoretical idea is
that this persistent
recurrent activation across multiple
Networks
leads to the formation
of durable memories within a single
episode
so what we have done is we've built a
mathematical not computational model and
a quantification of the Persistence of
activation that could be expected within
one of these episodic experiences
the model computes the momentary that is
transient working memory activation
within the system as a function of the
current sensory input to the child
the child's Behavior
and by cued activation from previous
events within the episode
and then from that we can compute
persistence over extended time right now
we're just looking at persistence as a
sum of the momentary activations
as an indicator of the likely formation
of durable and expressible memories
so
the mo this model
uh is in some ways not novel and
actually
is known to characterize human memory
our starting point is a well-documented
law like and highly conserved
uh spacing and repetition effects on
memory and we have just coupled these
with interactive Effects implicated by
the recent advances in the role of
predictive relations and repetitions
and learning of cute activations within
the episode itself
I'm not going to go into the nature of
the model it is a a series of dynamic
systems equations because everything
that happens at any moment
any any level of activation in the
system at any moment let's say time t n
depends on what happened at TN minus 1
which Depend and GN minus two and
there's multiple complex interacting
influences across all of these
all right
but what we can do
is we can take the uh data from
Individual children
the pandling by the parent and the child
the parent naming
and we can predict what the momentary
memory strength is and the persistence
is
from those experiences
and I put these two slides up here to
keep you in memory that
the frequency distribution of objects is
extremely skewed okay so as you can see
in the individual time series I put
forth here from four of our individual
participants the top three objects are
like filling much of the time they
really dominate them
all right so here are the uh predictive
momentary activations
and what you should see here is that the
frequency distribution of
individual experiences
is not so strongly evident in the
persistence or momentary activation
of the ex of by the model OKAY instead
what you see is that for many individual
children all the objects from the most
frequently to the least frequently from
the very tail of this tribution all have
persistent activation
throughout the play session okay
why does this happen this happens
because of the interrelations among the
objects because the boosts in memory by
Epping House are more potent when
they're farther apart in time and
because the boosts are more potent when
they are actually retrieved that is
formed through pattern completion
so what you have here is despite the
fact that you play with a few objects a
whole lot of the time
and most objects very little
the whole episode
gives forth a lot of memorability a lot
of memory persistence activation and
persistence
for all of the objects
this suggests to me that these
experiences are capable of building
memories of whole networks of experience
so maybe instead of thinking our
memories as being about a dog or about
dog images or being about the
co-occurrence of hearing the word dog
and seeing a dog we should think about
our memories as being networks of
the relations experienced within a
single individual episode and so what
the learning mechanisms are operating on
to give rise to the realization of
knowledge across experiences and in
using that knowledge to solve new
problems is
an internal system that operates not
over individual events or features but
that operates over the relational
structure of episodes of experience
how might this work well I can
illustrate what we're thinking about
through
um one example of innovative
generalization that I personally
observed okay so we have a young toddler
and that toddler of course knows that
his shoes go on his feet and he's had a
lot of experience with having his shoes
go on his feet and he probably knows
Mom's Shoes go on Mom's feet and Dad's
shoes go on Dad's feet
but one day he's given this is a
one-year-old a stuffed a toy an elephant
that has kind of cup like shoes on two
of its feet
here's the thing this toddler despite
never having seen this elephant or a
configuration like this elephant before
immediately knows the cupped
shaped black things on the bottom of the
two feet
our shoes
and Compares them to his own shoes
directly
shoot a shoe elephant to child shoe
later
that child
is playing on the floor of the kitchen
and goes to the cupboard
and takes then discovers cups and the
playthings covered
and fix them tries to fit them on his
own feet as shoes
how did the child do this
now this fitted fitting of these cups on
his shoes might strike you as too
precious and Too Cute Charming
but it is characteristic of young
children it's a phenomenon
but it is characteristic of young
children it is a phenomenon that is well
known in developmental psychology it's
called either symbolic play or object
substitutions in play and there are many
many documented cases using pots as hats
using pots as drums using bananas as
phones to call somebody
using boxes as trucks boxes is bad
sticks as bottles to feed a baby shoes
as boats
it's really remarkable these object
substitutions in play
characteristic of toddlers during the
same period they're learning words
it's not that these children think a
banana is a phone they are not fooled
it's not that they think a pot is a hat
what they see instead
is the possibility it really is
innovative
compellingly smart
the stop out of which invention and
Innovation and generative intelligence
comes from of doing something nobody's
ever done before
how on Earth do they learn to do this
learn how do they do it
let's think about a single episode and
shoes on feet as a path towards the way
in which this might happen this figure
here just illustrates a series of events
okay
uh that we have observed with its
structure sort of shown in the order of
the toys
the episode begins with the parents
sitting the toddler on the floor and
giving the toddler a giraffe to play
with while the parent goes to retrieve
socks from the door drawer but the child
sees a Cheerio on the floor and picks it
up putting the giraffe down
the parent puts one sock on the child's
foot sees that the child has an old
Cheerio takes the old Cheerio away and
re-gives a child the giraffe
before putting the second sock on the
child's foot
the parent reaches out for the shoes
which are nearby but at the same time
the dog emerges
and tries to take one
meanwhile
while the parent is dealing with the dog
the child pulls one sock off
the parent puts a sock back on the dog
approaches the shoes again
they're sort of laughter and talk about
the parent
keeps the shoe away from the dog gives
it to the child to hold
puts the shoe back on
puts a shoe on
gives a child the uh puts a shoe on
child finds another Cheerio the parent
takes it away
gives a child the giraffe to play with
while the second shoe is put on the foot
now what I want to do is think about you
to think about this structure just a
minute this example illustrates how day
in and day out experiences are extended
in Time episodes like we observed in toy
play how they're characterized by the
regularities a child needs to learn
shoes go on feet but how they are loaded
absolutely loaded with idiosyncrasies
multiple factors yesterday's dropped
Cheerios the child's momentary goals a
dog's Behavior the parents persistence
in achieving the objective of getting
shoes put on the child's feet all
converge to create a unique never to be
exactly repeated ever again
learning experience for the idea that
shoes go on feet
from the from the perspective of current
approaches to artificial intelligence
that this is what the structure of
experience is like you would think that
one would need many different
many many massive amounts of training
episodes to discover the generalized
principle that shoes go on feet because
you've got to discard all this other
irrelevant idiosyncrasies
but here's the thing
I think the idiosyncrasies matter I
think they're the source of innovation
so let's think about how this might work
the child before he got the elephant his
head multiple episodes on shoes on feet
his own is parents whatever shoes go on
feet
when he's presented with that elephant
those little black cops remind him
remind reactivate
those whole episodes okay
and he can see and and the recurring
relation in these very different
idiosyncratic episodes
of shoes on feet so across these very
different episodes just like you might
think would work he can find the common
relation across those different episodes
shoes go on feet and because they differ
so much
it's not hard to think that the black
things on the bottom of that elephant
are also shoes on feet
but here's where the uniqueness matters
this child now has one remembered
network of experience about the elephant
which lightened the shoes on the
elephant to his own shoes okay
when the child is playing with cups and
his little bare feet are in view this
might be sufficient across these two
across the remembered Network for the
elephant shoes and his own shoes
to try to put the cups on his feet
the uniqueness if we stripped away all
that was not about
uniquely correct shoes going on beat
human feet from all these memories that
Innovation wouldn't be there what
happens though is if you have memories
for The Unique parts of these episodes
of experience and their relations with
others you may be able to combine them
in ways that lead really truly to
innovation
so I began by saying much of the
knowledge out there in the world to be
learned as latent unrealized without
some direct physical action on the World
by the infant or by the infant social
partner
these Behavior generated creations of
data
are continuous in time and have a temple
structure
and I think we ought to entertain the
idea that the secret sauce
for human generative intelligence lies
in the structure of these con individual
Behavior generated episodes of
experience
and I think this has lessons
for those of us who want to understand
the origin and nature
of human generative intelligence and for
those who might like to reverse engineer
um
that kind of intelligence
I think first off we need to really
study the temple structure of real-time
experiences these are where we want
both people and machines to function
well and so the internal processes that
operate and function learn from and
function
in the context of real life
need to be aligned with whatever the
temporal structure of those experiences
are
right now a lot of people thinking about
learning and generalization and far
generalization have their eyes on what I
think of as like the forest massive
amounts of data how different and how
much we can get and just gather it
gather it gather it gather it and what
I'm suggesting instead is that we need
to study the individual trees and the
data
that's
the level of experience as it's lived
one tree at a time one shoes on feet
experience at a time
and then I think the power in these
individual experiences
May lie in the idiosyncratic properties
of each individual experience not
because the idiosyncratic gets to be
removed so you can filtered out so you
just have the one abstract relation but
because all these idiosyncratic pieces
provide lessons for multiple different
problems for thinking about elephants as
well as thinking about shoes
and that those reminders and
interconnections
are where Innovation comes from
and we need to think about those
individual trees and those individual
lessons understand the system of
relational patterns I believe I've
probably just uncovered the tiniest
little bit of what might matter here and
I may have missed even the most
important parts I think that's highly
likely
and finally I think the other reason for
really focusing in on the structure of
real-time experience is because of the
alignment between the learning mechanism
and the data itself at least in human
behavior and human intelligence we make
our own data
and we make it with the same mechanisms
that do the learning
all right I want to finish by just
noting that I've only talked about
one time scale in this work the sort of
single episode time scale which I'm just
very excited about what it can do now
for solving some kinds of problems but
it is the case that development itself
presents an ordered curriculum of
development in which there are long
periods which may serve as niches for
solving specific kinds of problems
and the organization of those niches the
kinds of experiences that are
interleaved with one another probably
also play an important role in how
humans at any rate end up as they do
all right with that I would like to
thank my
um amazing lab members
um and of course all the people who
support my my work including the
National Science Foundation the national
Eye Institute National Institute for
child health and human development as
well as Indiana University through its
special initiative learning brains
machines and children okay thank you
very much